okay first question
third row in the middle
Mark stalwart Miami Times uh Jimmy you
play for Larry O'Brien uh no one from
here on out that the trophy will be in
the building what's the mentality on
Monday night
uh same thing it's always been it's a
game at a time
now we're in a must-win situation every
single game which we're capable of some
correctable things that we got to do but
um it's not impossible so we got we got
to go out there and do it we got three
to get
we're gonna go the right side first row
Cooper morehead.com Kyle they had 19
makes in the restricted area and 13 Cuts
so even though yogurts are married and
have the most efficient nights what were
they doing to get behind the defense I
think we were up a little higher you
know trying to make sure that uh we
showed bodies on there coming off the
pick and roll a couple of their Cuts
were kind of you know just random and
kind of just landed in their lap
but um you know I think we just got to
find a way to kind of keep the ball in
front of us and yeah
it happened tonight they got good Cuts
tonight
we're going to go in the far right side
and back row Jimmy Nick friedel ESPN
what is the biggest message you want to
impart to the team over the course of
the next couple days heading into Monday
um no doubt
um we don't have any of that
when I have no quit we're gonna
continually fight starting tomorrow to
get better and then we're gonna go on a
Monday and and do what we said we're
gonna do this entire time and when we
have to we have no other choice
otherwise we did all this for no reason
so the guys know we know
um we got something to do
we're gonna go to the first row in the
middle Jimmy Rohan not here any Sports
Illustrated I think this regular season
was your highest efficiency offensively
in your career we kind of saw that
carried through the first round this
series it's been a little bit more up
and down do you feel like it's just a
matter of you not making the shots you
normally get or is there another
challenge that they presented that's
gonna hurt you that way
it's always a make or Miss game it's a
maker missile League
I missed some shots
that's just part of it but I don't I
don't think missing shots for our team
will ever make us win or lose a game I
think we have some lapses and you know
not getting back the cuts to offensive
rebounds those are the the areas that we
can control that we do have to fix so
whether I'm missing shots or anybody
else is missing shots
um those are the areas that we got to be
better at
we're gonna stay in the middle Melissa
roll on Fox Sports um Jimmy is there a
commonality to how you guys have
overcome every obstacle that you guys
have faced this season and if so what's
the approach to obviously what will be
your greatest one
um I think so I just think we we really
do believe in one another in ourselves
as individuals so we've done some hard
things all year long in this playoff run
as well and now it's like the hardest of
the heart but like we always say you
know the things that you want is on the
other side of heart is I don't know what
um so that's where we're at
um that's our reality so we got to go
out and win three straight second row in
the middle
Jimmy Vince gillwell Yahoo sports you
repeatedly said throughout this series
that you're going to keep kicking the
ball out to your Shooters no matter if
they're hitting shots but they miss Nine
in a row you'll kick it out to them for
a 10th they've repeatedly struggled at
some point in this series do you feel
like you need to be more aggressive
yourself taking shots that you don't
normally want to take just to switch up
the juju of the defense and maybe try to
get a different result
no I won't do it um I I got I got too
much faith in my guys
um their shots will fall
they've been the reason behind us
winning so many games and I'm not I'm
not letting that faith in them waiver I
won't do it I'm gonna continue to play
basketball the right way pump confidence
in those guys and we're gonna always
live with the results
we're going to go on the left side in
the back
the Eureka for the German basket
magazine a question for both of you
um suppose said that you guys are like
made for that that you need those games
where you have a must win situation so
would you both would agree that you need
those games like the next upcoming that
you're in a must-win situation
go ahead go ahead
um I think we understand we have to
thrive and we we gotta win and um I
think it heightens our intensity
um you know I think you know he's gonna
go home right now and you know we're
we've been our intensity has been pretty
high and uh but when you get in these
situations you have to really be focused
on every second literally every second
last question in the first row
it's will Giller with the Athletico uh
Gabe has talked throughout the playoffs
about you know your mentorship and how
much you've helped in the past couple
years uh back-to-back tough games for
him just was kind of your message to him
to help him kind of get back on track uh
going into game five I think just uh
being ready to play I mean Gabe's an
unbelievable this whole playoff run this
last couple months
um games at a tremendous basketball
player
um you know our league is a maker
misleague and you got a guy named Jimmy
Butler who's going to continue to pump
uh confidence into him I'm a pump
confidence into him he's going to come
on have a great game game five he's
gonna uh get you know we're all going to
get some rest recover and uh getting
that playing tomorrow with the with the
with the mission in mind
thank you guys
thank you